ethiopia has begun filling the
reservoirs of a controversial mega dam
on the blue nile that's according to the
country's water minister
egypt and sudan had requested the grand
renaissance dam
not be filled until an agreement is
reached there's been nearly a decade of
contentious negotiation over concerns
it could drastically reduce water
supplies to downstream countries
ethiopia has said the dam is crucial for
its growth
and will begin filling it during this
month's rainy season
charles stratford lays out the politics
behind the dam
it's taken ten years to build and cost
close to five billion dollars
ethiopia's flagship infrastructure
project is a great source of national
pride but the grand ethiopian
renaissance dam on the blue nile has
caused tension with downstream countries
sudan and egypt
from the start the ethiopian government
says the hydroelectric dam is vital for
the development of this immense
landlocked country which has a
population of around 108 million
the country plans to export electricity
across the region
and says the dam will stop seasonal
flooding in neighboring sudan
but egypt says there are a number of
outstanding legal issues that need
resolving
and filling the reservoir too quickly
could reduce its water supply
and may pose an existential threat egypt
does have legitimate concerns i mean the
egypt relies
on denial for 90 percent of its fresh
water needs
uh and the largest share of the river
runs through egypt through egyptian
territory
uh and what we have as in egypt is a
situation where they have a
significant gap between the amount of
water they produce
and the amount of water they consume
and with a rapidly growing population of
over 100 million
it points to this problem only getting
worse
ethiopia also has strong claims because
it's the source of the blue nile
the largest of the river niles
tributaries ethiopia was never included
in a colonial era agreement between
egypt and sudan
that gives the lion's share of water to
egypt
there are many finely balanced
calculations including internal
political ones that are a play here
you know for example in ethiopia you
have abi ahmed having come into power in
2018
he wants to secure his position and and
you know be re-elected in future
elections in ethiopia
in egypt you have president sisi with
you know an economy that has
had been struggling but also he needs to
ensure
that he has the continued backing of the
military establishment in the country
which of course has an important role in
that
economy in late june ethiopia rejected a
u.n security council meeting requested
by egypt
saying the council should not be
involved at all
ethiopia's u.n ambassador said the
dispute should be solved at a regional
level
african union talks hosted by south
africa failed to forge agreement earlier
that month
in february the u.s and the world bank
mediated what it hoped would be a road
map on how to proceed with final
technical and legal issues which
concerned egypt in particular
but ethiopia did not sign the final
document
ethiopia always said that it would have
preferred agreement
before it begins to fill the reservoir
but if that wasn't possible it would go
ahead anyway
it has potential huge security
implications for the entire region
ethiopia accuses egypt of repeatedly
dragging its feet over the issue of
filling the reservoir
something it says egypt knew would be
inevitable
one day charles stratford al jazeera
our correspondent hippo morgan's joining
us live from now from northern state in
sudan um do we have any idea about what
uh sudan's reaction is going to be
well rob we're yet to hear a new
reaction
or any statement from the chinese
government uh we've heard from them
yesterday saying that
uh they are going to present a report to
the uh
african union they've already submitted
reports from the two weeks
of talks of virtual talks between
ethiopia sudan and egypt
to their prime ministers and uh there is
supposed to be a summit that is uh
going to take place between the prime
ministers of the three countries
within the coming week now this was all
to try to make sure that
appeal is reached before ethiopia starts
filling its grand dam now this is
obviously
a little bit too late for that uh there
have been repeated concerns from sudan
about the safety of the operations of
the dam
let's not forget that sudan itself has
another dam that's about 100 kilometers
away
from the girl the grand island
renaissance dam which is called the
ferris
so it's quite concerned about what would
happen when the dam fails to operate
properly
and fails to hold water and all of a
sudden all that water
that has been held by the reservoir gets
released downstream all of them will not
be able to handle repairs itself
has the capacity of seven thousand
that's uh
that's about ten times less less than
the uh grand
dam of ethiopia so lots of concerns
there egypt of course we know has been
uh very concerned about the killing of
the dam because that will affect
the water levels it has uh which more
than 90 percent of its population relies
on so
lots of concerns there were yet to hear
reactions from the vietnamese government
they've repeatedly said that there
should be a diplomatic solution
and that there should be a political
will to reach a deal which is why
they've been trying to meditate between
the two sides while saying that it at
the same time is a stakeholder
so lots of concerns here about how to
handle the coming three steps
over the coming few days now that the
first step of the dam has actually
started
i would understand that um people living
in and around the dam are also going to
be concerned about
uh safety issues uh the the same safety
issues that sudan has
is there any effort that sudan can make
at least in governmental terms to try to
protect people who might be affected
well as you heard from my colleagues uh
when he
reported just a few minutes ago that uh
if you have said that the dam
will control seasonal flooding uh along
the nile in sudan that's something that
sedan has repeatedly suffered from
especially during the rainy season
flooding uh along the banks of the nile
as the nile flows from
uh the country towards egypt now the dam
will control that however
that is what farmers say uh they mean
we've spoken to farmers along the nile
from pronounced state
uh on the border with if you're here all
the way up to uh alpha
uh on the border with egypt they say
that they need that uh
that motion of the flooding uh from the
nile uh to be able to uh have
a more fertile soil to be able to uh
irrigate their plants
properly so while we have heard people
uh complaining about the floods over the
past few
years they say that those floods that
have been
uh happening uh recurring uh annually is
very important
so that they would be able to uh
continue farming and continue to
continue producing there are a lot of
farmland
agricultural profound land along the
banks of the mile as we go down uh
northwards from uh from sudan borders
going on to egypt so lots of concerns by
the farmers
about what will happen when the water
levels drop on the nile
tiber morgan reporting to us from sudan
hibba thanks very much indeed
alice katopoulos has more on where the
concerns lie for egypt and sudan
ethiopia's largest hydroelectric project
has been controversial since its
beginning
in 2011. but what is it about the grand
ethiopian renaissance dam
that has egypt and sudan so concerned
let's start with what it can do for
ethiopia itself
a country of more than 109 million
people its economy is one of the fastest
growing in the world
at roughly 10 a year for the last 15
years
ethiopia's energy demands have kept pace
but only 27 percent of the country is
currently connected to the national grid
this dam the largest in africa spans the
blue nile
and will produce a whopping 6450
gigawatts when it's fully operational
three times as much as egypt's has one
high dam giving ethiopia the ability
to connect every single citizen to the
electricity grid
drive its economy and still have energy
left over to export to its neighbors
sudan djibouti somalia and kenya
so far so good then what is the issue
a big dam needs a big reservoir and this
one will be huge
at 1 840 square kilometers
it will hold more than two and a half
times the amount of water in lake
tana ethiopia's largest lake and the
source of the blue nile
the dam will take years to fill and the
fear is it will reduce the water flowing
downstream to sudan and egypt
currently 86 of the blue nile flows from
ethiopia
the river provides 77 of fresh water for
sudan
and 93 of egypt's if there is a
reduction in the water flowing through
these desert countries
it could have a serious impact on
agriculture and livelihoods
other hydroelectric projects like
egypt's as one high dam
currently producing six percent of
egypt's electricity would also be
greatly affected
egypt and sudan's populations are
rapidly growing and within the resource
needs but for ethiopia
the 4 billion dam is a way out of
poverty
and an end to decades of rolling
blackouts with global warming and
changing weather patterns
managing scarce resources is becoming
increasingly vital alex skatopoulos
al jazeera